first question for you
given the fact that andy would have had
to have seen light year in order to want
the toy it makes me wonder do you
remember the very first movie that you
saw that made you have to run out and
buy the toys from that phone god good
question and probably it was probably uh
teenage mutant ninja turtles like the
first one the original one oh yeah that
was like the oh i mean come on it was so
good and um i i remember
needing every single toy that they
possibly made it was right there with
you it was ninja turtles and jurassic
park
i mean thundercats was really big for me
he-man was really big and they made that
movie masters of the universe with dolph
lundgren that was a great movie i still
vividly remember what those toys in the
90s looked like too yeah great i mean
come on i still have them in my closet
somewhere i mean i do now my niece plays
with my jurassic park toys and it fills
my heart so much
all right another movie story inspired
question for you so one of my absolute
favorite parts in the movie is when
buzzes were calling going through
training and he wasn't really good at
training but alicia saw something in him
and then he became the space ranger we
know him to be for you as an actor is
there anyone who saw something in you
back in the day when you were having a
tough time that kind of you know put you
on the path that you're on today i mean
i'm very lucky my parents were always
really really supportive um i had a
couple good uh local theater directors
when i was a kid you know you do
community theater and kids theater and
things like that so there were a couple
people who
certainly encouraged me and gave me the
confidence to believe that i had
something that was worth pursuing um but
but probably more than anyone else my
parents you know and i mean they're the
ones that kind of but i mean i suppose
that's probably the case with a lot of
people but you know anything i did they
told me it was
the best i'm grateful to say the same is
true for me so now with the voice of the
character you just have the greatest
creative opportunity here because on the
one hand you need to be able to connect
it to the character we know from the
original toy story movies but
technically he is not the same person so
what was it like finding that pitch
perfect balance that people immediately
make the connection but also understand
that he's a unique individual yeah well
it's it's nice to have what
tim did because not only did he do it so
well and you know we all love him
for what his performance was but but the
character actually is i mean this is the
human version of the toy so it's not
like you're you know doing james bond or
something where you get to play an
iconic role but with a completely fresh
take this is an iconic role but informed
very much in part by what tim did
whatever this character is would have to
be why tim is the way he was so you just
kind of take his performance as a
blueprint and just move upstream it's a
very smart uh approach to the story i'm
fascinated why work hard when someone's
already knocked it out of the park you
know just steal if you can yeah you do a
lot with it yourself too
so it's been a very very long time since
you've done another animated feature was
there anything about making a pixar
movie today that you know you back then
would think like i can't believe that
this is how they make animated movies
today well i mean it's so funny everyone
always says like what was it like
working with the other actors you don't
work with the other actors you're in a
booth by yourself i didn't even meet
half the actors until last night at the
premiere
so so it's
it's a very isolating thing and you
really end up focusing extremely on the
one string you're playing on which is
your voice
sometimes you'd give a certain delivery
that you felt was authentic but then
you'd hear it back and it might feel a
little
flat then you realize okay i can add a
little more you know sauce to this you
can put some color in onto it and really
um
trust that that they'll
pick and choose what is appropriate for
the moment but but have fun with it you
know you can't go big enough because the
master's over there you couldn't be in
better hands on the folks at pixar
something else